um
so for today's class what we are going
to talk about
is uh generative models for graphs right
so far we were
working under assumption or we talked
about methods where
a given where we said a graph is given
and we want to do some modeling
learning prediction community detection
on top of it
what we are going to look at for the
next two lectures
is a different problem it is a problem
about how do we
um generate a graph right how would we
generate
a synthetic social network how would we
generate a synthetic economic network
how would we generate a synthetic
communication network right how are what
are some of the processes that would
allow us to generate these types of
graphs
right um and the way we can uh we can do
this
is that we want to generate realistic
graphs using generative models right so
the idea will be that
we are given a graph generative
model and we want to be able then to uh
generate a synthetic graph that is
somehow similar or
matches uh the real graph so this is
what we would uh
like to do so why do we want to
do graph generation why should we care
uh
first is that we want to understand how
real graphs form right so these
these generative models can provide us
insights about
what kind of processes take place let's
say in social science
in in humans when we generate when we
create
our own uh social networks and social
connections
uh it allows us to make predictions in a
sense you know how do we expect
this graph to evolve uh in the future um
synthetic graphs are also very useful
because they
allow us to understand um various kinds
of processes
that lead to a generation of
new graphs and then we can use them as
data sets for understanding corner cases
and
understanding the performance of various
kinds of graph methods
and the last is about anomaly detection
in a sense that
we many times require a null model a
model that would say
this is what i would expect this is the
network i would expect
let me compare it now to the real world
network and see what the differences are
right so we want this type of
null models to then be able to have a
reference point
for what is expected and then whatever
real data we have we can kind of compare
it to that
um expected reference point to the
uh to the to the null model so uh the
roadmap for graph generation and for the
lecture today is the following
first i'm actually going to talk to you
about properties of real-world graphs
right because when i generate a graph i
want to
fit some properties i want to match some
properties
of the real network and the question is
what properties are interesting and what
properties should we try to match
and then i'm going to talk about the
second part of the lecture about
traditional graph generative models uh
where basically each comes with a
different set of assumptions these
models are
relatively simple but they come up with
a lot of insight and they really allow
us to kind of understand
the network formation and then uh next
week tuesday
i'm going to talk about uh deep graph
generative models where we want to learn
the graph formulation process from data
and this is what we are going to cover
in the next lecture so today's lecture
won't be kind of
machine learning flavor it will be more
about traditional graph generation
and a lot of cool insights and then next
lecture will be
thinking about graph generation as a
purely machine learning process
and of course there is value in both
there is value in
formulating things as pure machine
learning problems where you say i want
to predict
the graph um and there is also value in
um generating graphs through these
traditional models because that
comes up with a lot of theory a lot of
insights
and much more kind of inductive bias
into underlying processes that could be
taking place
in these networks so the plan
is to ask first what are some of the
important properties
of networks uh that let's say these
generators should match or that we can
compare
the generated network and the real
network and in particular we are going
to characterize graphs we are going to
measure graphs
according to these four uh different
properties first we'll call
degree distribution clustering
coefficient
connected components and uh the
shortest path lengths um and we are we
have introduced some of this
uh notions already at the beginning of
the class
so let's do a quick uh recap so first
degree distribution degree distribution
simply says
what is the probability that a randomly
chosen node will have a given degree
um and simply this is just a normalized
count right you say
it's in some sense a normalized
histogram where you say ah for
every degree k i want to ask what
fraction of nodes has that degree and i
can simply plot
degree versus fraction of nodes with
that degree and i can think of this as
normalized histogram or if i ignore this
uh
factor n then it's simply a histogram of
the
count versus degree right how many nodes
have a give
different have a given degree that's
what is called degree distribution
the second thing we already talked about
is clustering
coefficient which is all about trying to
understand
how connected are the neighbors of a
given node
um and in particular we say clustering
coefficient of node i
is simply defined twice the number of
edges between its neighbors divided by
the degree of the node times the degree
of the node minus 1.
so clustering coefficient will have
value between 0 and 1
and the reason why it is this way is
basically saying i have k neighbors
so k times k minus 1 divided by 2 is
k choose 2 it's number of possible pairs
of neighbors you can select
so this is the the total number of edges
that is possible
between a pair of nodes uh a pair of
neighbors of a given node with degree k
sub i
and e sub i is actually the actual
number of
edges that that occur right so if i have
no edges between the neighbors then
clustering coefficient is zero
if i let's say have three out of six
possible ones then
clustering coefficient is one half and
if i have all the six
edges between the four neighbors that
are possible then my clustering
coefficient is one and this is now
defined clustering coefficient of a
given node
now if you wanna do the clustering
coefficient of an entire network
what people usually do is they simply
compute the average clustering
coefficient
across all the nodes or they define or
they actually plot the distribution
of clustering coefficient values so
those are
two ways how to characterize this notion
of how many triangles how often
a friend of a friend is also a friend
right you can say basically
how likely am i to see this kind of
edges between
pairs of nodes that have a friend in
common and in social networks in
particular
clustering coefficients tend to be very
high because of this triadic closure
that we have discussed in the last
lecture about community detection
um so these were the first two degree
distribution clustering coefficient
the third one we will look at is
connectivity and in lecture one we
decide we just defined this notion of
the
uh connected components in the graph and
we said that
let's one thing how we can simply
characterize connectivity is to ask
what is the largest connected component
size right what what fraction of nodes
belongs to the largest connected
component so if i have some graph that
it may not be connected
i'm asking what fraction of nodes are in
the largest connected component where
connected component is simply
a pair of a set of nodes that can reach
each other let's say on an undirected
network
um the way i find connected components
is by simple
breadth first search and i would say
that you know giant component exists
if if this largest component is largest
i know more than half of
the nodes belong uh to this largest
connected component
and then the last thing that the way we
are going to characterize networks
is through what is called shortest path
lengths or the notion of diameter
so mathematically we define the diameter
of the network as the maximum
shortest path distance between any pair
of nodes in the graph so you take
essentially to compute it it would mean
take any pair of nodes and find the
shortest path between them
um now the problem with this maximum is
that you can have a long string of edges
somewhere and that will severely
increase your diameter of the graph
so for real networks you want to use
this some more robust measure of the
diameter for example
average shortest path length where you
say let me go over
all pairs of nodes i and j that are
connected
and let me uh let me compute the average
um
shortest path length between uh any pair
of nodes
um and you know many times if the graph
is disconnected
then the shortest path length between
two nodes that are in different
components is infinite
so you would only do this over the
largest connected component
or you would ignore pairs of nodes that
are not reachable from
each other but the idea is that you want
to get some sense of how many hops it
takes to get from one node to another
on average in this network
so these are the now four different ways
how do we
mathematically uh empirically
characterize
properties of a given network and just
for the uh
case for the kind of for the rest of the
lecture i'm going to use
one realistic large scale network
that we are going to characterize and
then we will say can we come up with a
generative model that could generate
this network so for example what we are
going to use is we are going to use a
network coming from this chat
application called
uh microsoft instant messenger so this
was like a
whatsapp slack type
application before all this all these
other services
existed you know uh it has uh uh
it had at that time it had around 250
million uh monthly active users about
180 million actually
engaged in conversations there were more
than
30 billion conversations over a month so
about uh
one billion conversations a day and you
know um
hundreds of billions of exchanged uh
messages so what we can do with this now
is we can take this communication
data and we can represent this as a
graph so the way we are going to
represent this as a graph is we are
going to put
will have people um and we will connect
to people if they exchange at least one
message
and here is actually the dots here
represent the geographic locations
of the users of this microsoft instant
messenger and basically what you see is
that
they come from all over the world um
except from north korea right it seems
that you know there was no users in
north korea but everywhere else
there are some users of this thing so in
total we'll now have a network of
180 million people with 1.3
billion undirected edges between them
so now let's start characterizing this
network let's start measuring it and say
how does this communication network of
you know people all over the world
exchanging uh short messages look like
so the first thing we can do is we can
characterize the degree distribution so
what i'm plotting here
is simply the degree of the node this is
number of different people
a given node exchange messages with in a
given month
um times and on the y-axis is the number
of uh such nodes with such degrees so i
i plot the count so it's
probability times the total number of
nodes so it's kind of an unnormalized
histogram right um what do you see you
see this super
funny strange uh however you want to
call it uh
interesting um histogram right it seems
that basically
there is this huge number right like
notice these dots here
of nodes that have the degree very close
to zero so basically
a lot of p
know you have maybe only one person with
the talks to 2000 other people and
and the person or the bot or whatever
this thing was
uh that talks to the most people was
about 6 000 right so it means out of 180
million people
there is one node whose maximum degree
is only six thousand right out of 180
million possible people to talk to
this bot only talks to uh six thousand
so what is very interesting is that this
histogram is kind of very much
axis aligned right it seems a lot of
people or a lot of nodes with super
small degrees
and you know just one node uh one
one count for every degree that is that
is you know higher than just you know
this
super small number um so this does not
seem
kind of this plot does not reveal too
much but
what you can do is you take the same
data but you just plot it differently
the way we are going now to re-plot this
data is we are going to replot it on on
logarithmic
scales on logarithmic axis so what we
did now it's exactly the same data
the same counts the same degrees but now
this axis is logarithmic right here is
here is hundred here is a thousand and
now all of a sudden you see this very
nice
shape right you see that basically i
have majority of the nodes yeah this is
10 to the seven so that's you know
10 million um 50 million nodes that you
know have degree one
two three so large majority of the nodes
have degree less than ten
and then you see how here at the end we
have very few nodes you know maybe one
two nodes
um for each degree above uh several
hundred and
you know the largest degree here i said
is uh six thousand so now you see this
beautiful pattern appeared that before
was not obvious at all like when i plot
this on linear scales just the histogram
it's just axis aligned i i don't even
know how to
interpret this right here now on same
data just the axis are different i'm
basically plotting
log degree versus log count i see this
uh
very nice uh shape uh this kind of what
is called a heavy tailed or a
power law distribution that people like
to
call these types of shapes so the second
thing is
how about clustering coefficient if we
take this network and compute clustering
coefficient
we find out that the clustering
coefficient of this network is
0.11 so it means that you know 11
of the of the neighbors are connected
with each other
um and that may seem a little
but it's actually a lot and the reason
why this is a lot is because you have
this
super large degree nodes um right that
have a lot of possible connections
between the friends
um and uh actually it turns out that
point eleven
uh is is quite a lot right now it seems
like oh you know the clustering
coefficient is between zero and one
you know point eleven is kind of closer
to zero than closer to one
so it seems that clustering of this msn
network is low
but because we will have null models we
are actually able to establish that the
clustering is actually quite high
so let me now tell you why why point 11
is high
and you know why is it not low even
though it seems kind of a tiny number
so this is what we are going to figure
out so
this was clustering now uh
the third metric was connectivity right
how big is the largest connected
component
and what i'm plotting here is the size
of the connected component how many
nodes belong to a given component versus
number of
components of such a size what do you
see is that the largest connected
component
has about 200 over more than right this
is 10 to the 8 is
100 million so this is you know
almost like close to 200 million so
pretty much 99.9 percent of all the
nodes belong to the largest connected
component so the network is connected
and of course then we have you know some
small number of very small components of
you know
20 30 nodes all the way to uh
let's say one million of nodes of that
are isolated so connected components of
size one
so this means that our graph is well
connected with a very small number
of uh small sm very small
isolated islands but the giant component
is definitely there
and 99.9 percent of all the nodes uh
belong to it
and then the last thing i want to
mention is the shortest path length
so here is the distribution of uh
shortest path lens between different
across pairs of nodes so i ask here how
many pairs of nodes
are at shortest path distance five you
know how many are at
shortest path distance ten and so on uh
and here the y-axis is logarithmic
so notice that most pairs of nodes are
reachable
uh with each other in around five
six uh hops so it means
actually that the average shortest path
length of this giant network of 180
million people
living all over the world is only 6.6
and it turns out that you can reach 90
percent of the nodes of this network
on average in less than eight hops so it
takes you
eight friendships to get to uh ninety
percent of the nodes and just to
give you another way how you can think
of this is to say let's start
breath for search at a given node right
so at
zero steps it is one node now this node
has degree ten so at step one
there is ten other nodes i can reach
right then this
ten nodes have further connect to other
nodes so at step two i am
a at 75 nodes and notice
how the uh how the number how the number
of reachable nodes increases
and here for example at steps uh
six seven and eight i'm i i can reach
you know 28 millions
80 million 52 million and then again you
see how this quickly uh decays
down where you know the the at hub
distance 25
i could still reach uh three more nodes
so notice again basically this kind of
shape
here demonstrated by this single node uh
uh example so this is um what i wanted
to show
in terms of the shortest path length
right it's even though our network is
massive
the the amount of um
the the shortest path lengths tend to be
very very very small
and this is what is called uh the small
world phenomena
right that basically even though the
network is large the diameter the
shortest path lengths are actually quite
small in these networks
so what we have seen so far is that
there are key properties of this
messenger network right the degree
distribution is heavily skewed
average degrees degrees about 14
clustering coefficient is 0.11
connectivity has one giant component
with 99.9 percent of the nodes
and the average shortest path length is
6.6
and as i give you these numbers right
you should be asking yourself
are these values expected are they
surprising
you know is there should i make fuss
about it or you know we just forget
about it like is it interesting
what does this teach us right and in
order for us to determine whether
whether this is interesting is that we
need we need a null model so basically
what we are going to look at next is
different null models
on which we can make the same
measurements and then be able to say aha
you know messenger network has high
clustering coefficient
messenger network has i don't know uh
low low low average path length or
something like that because we'll have
this
reference point so what we are going to
talk about next is
talk about this reference points these
types of models